our community responsible men with
morals are turn off we are not exciting
enough
where are these responsible men with
morals
you don't meet black men that are
responsible and in general no black men
in general black men I've met a few
responsible black men so why did you say
where are they at them the male
Community I don't see many where did you
meet them
um School uni
um interesting yeah maybe like if you
like go to church or something you might
find you might get finesse blood I don't
know
yeah yeah yeah yeah so so yeah where do
you think you meet like if you want a
decent black guy here that's not
drilling and trapping I know that hurts
a nice difficult to kind of get out of
your programming but if you wanted to
settle down and he's like no I've had
enough of guys like King riches
I want a good boy put yourself you don't
even want a military guy like my boy
there he's murking people you want a
good clean cut boy bruv yeah man where
where do you think you would go starting
from you and we're gonna end with you I
don't think it works like that like I'm
not gonna go to a library to find the
love of my life like where would you go
then it's not where would I go like he's
like people like for example I've met
people on nights out that are no
criminals they work nine to five they
they earn six figures
no he's not sure I rarely go out in
shortage like what I'm trying to say
what I'm trying to say is like all these
boxes like oh my God we need to go to
the library we need to go to the church
to find these guys like no these guys
are out there like these guys also so
basically what you're saying they're not
in any particular place so you might as
well just go to the club because you've
met nice guys no he's not might as well
go to the club like they can be anywhere
it's not like we can't put them in a box
I call these guys in the lab is in the
like you know what I mean
being put together in the lab no he's in
the lab working on something like I
don't think uh I won't go anywhere to
find like the love of my life all my my
future husband like the guy said that
the guys yeah yeah I'm gonna ask you a
question I'm gonna ask everyone the same
stuff here all right so
um what do you look for in a guy
um physically what what are your
required like what do you look for
dating preferences what your preferences
and
by a black guy but then what kind of
black guy like looks was
um like thick because like I'm not too
slim what do you mean like the way we
talked about like a thick guy but he
doesn't I don't care I don't care if you
have muscles if you have abs like I'm
not very that bored like just being not
strong yeah just be like thick built
because like I'm not very slim so like I
don't want to be like next week
you're gonna back it up and then
[Laughter]
all right cool what about height
as long as it's like the same as me
above like oh yeah I'm not oh that's
that's cute does he have to make
um how much money should he make a year
do you reckon
because you're doing well in it you're
living your best life that was your word
yeah they can earn less than me like
it's not about the money because maybe
he's working on something uh and in a
few years he's gonna earn more than me
so I feel like that money like as long
as he's working hard towards something
uh or like uh towards like his goals
like imagine if I date a broke guy right
now because he's investing in his
business and his business is gonna blow
in a few years time so he's not really
like the money that he has at the moment
but his goals and what he's working so
you don't mind paying for all the dates
here
no no I don't mind sure
hakkasan no but I don't I don't do that
anyways I'm not a person to go on dates
and go to expensive restaurants I don't
mind to go to the chicken and chip shops
if oh it's okay you know so I feel like
it depends on who you are as well
because there's guys that they like to
go to expensive restaurants but I'm not
the type of girl so
yeah it depends on who you're dating
yeah that's good still all right the
Nova what have you got for us where do
we where did the women find where did
the the black where where does all the
respectable black women yeah
like where did they find good black guys
so they don't have to date Drillers yeah
and then after yeah let me I want to ask
you what kind of guys do you go for
physically
cool so I think that if you want I think
you need to turn yourself into the
person that fits that's the type of man
you want so for example
um a lot of some of the guys I met that
I believe are you know suitable
bachelors and everything a lot of them I
met them at Uni because not because that
you need to be educated but it's a sort
of mindset that you may have so Norm not
all the time but usually you know at Uni
you mean like-minded people you grow
together and you create like a parallel
no but that was one of them I met I've
got a lot of guy friends from uni a lot
of guys I think you'd be great husband
material you know that was one of the
environments why didn't you pick one of
them then
uh because I had one of them and the one
that I did love and it was my everything
actually went back to Nigeria it was an
international student which means things
kind of like had to dress it was a
foreign export yeah and actually I'll
tell you something International
um students a lot of them are good men
actually they come from good backgrounds
because they have to be able to come
forward to being everything so they tend
to have like sometimes more functional
house homes and everything like that
another place I would say is networking
events is great because people that's
searching for uh sort of knowledge it's
all about people that's searching for
development whatever whatever all right
cool so what kind of guys do you like
like what like what looks wise what do
you look for
be honest strong big black man
strong big black man
so like what how tall are you and how
tall does the guy have to be I'm five
foot six
um
I would ideally like ideally at six foot
plus reason being because I that's
usually how I feel protected by a man
not because
um he needs to really be that my dad was
a huge big ass black man he's the first
person that I look to for protection and
love and things like this so I guess
I've got a bit of a mirroring of that
onto my ideal partner I guess okay all
right moving on to young lady in the
middle what was the first question all
right where should a woman find a good
black man no actually regardless of
black or white where should a woman find
a good black man and then I wanna know
what are your dating preferences for a
black man
I think my answer to the question is
yeah there's more good men good men
traditionally however in what concept
we're speaking and out there then there
is all these other men so women just
need to look within themselves
and really do a 180 on their filtering
system on the type of guys they're going
for and change that because you'll see
that I think a lot of women think oh
there's I can't find anybody and it's
like it's not that you're not looking in
the right places or whatever else it may
be but you're you're blinded you're
turning a blind eye to these people
because you're looking for the wrong
things in a particular type of man so I
think it's more within look at yourself
look at what you want for yourself as a
woman in your life and then
flip what you've been looking for or
what you've been finding somewhat
attractive in these men that haven't
done nothing for you and
go out and look and you'll see these men
they're here they're everywhere like
like I said I believe the majority are
good men and then you're all agreeing
but you all said you would prefer the
drug dealer and scammer over the good
nine to five guys
they say anything
but yeah so all right what so uh yeah
the preferences
um how tall are you I'm five two so I
have never animals what can I do as long
as you're taller than me It's gotta be
six or five no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no I don't like a man that's
way too too anyways because
you're short you know thank you
um but also I I'm a boxing coach so I
come from a martial arts background so I
think a man that has something this is
another one that was a thick guy it's
not a thick guy you've got to be thick
no you are not thick enough for me no I
think just someone that is somewhat fit
someone that is somewhat active someone
that has
um some form of martial arts background
for me would be
[Music]
[Laughter]
what do you think about it I say
probably you should look around your
network or your circle because like
friends of friends would kind of be able
to vet a person for you before you even
having to do the Dirty Work you know so
that's like an uh a step forward and
then yeah I think yeah your your circle
or maybe outside your circle by a bit
and yeah you kind of
have someone who could have similar
interests to you or like you could have
someone who has similar morals to you so
it makes life a little bit easier as for
like the features that I find attractive
I like Teeth I have a weird thing for
teeth teeth if he's got good nice nice
sensitive teeth teeth with a nice set of
canines that's that's nice
and a nice back
[Music]
[Laughter]
but all right so you made like a big
backlight yeah
one question for all three do you go do
girls prefer guys four four sorry or do
you prefer a guy with like love handles
something to grab hold up
do you prefer a guy like that's got
muscles like a musty guy that goes to
the gym a guy with love hand always
something that you can grab hold of like
a country I like a cuddly person I think
it's like a bit of meat yeah
I like Timber I like it Timber is like
mussels you don't you don't necessarily
that's crazy that's crazy as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
his
arm
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible